Yeah.
Hi, Brandy. Good afternoon.
Hello, how are you? Are you feeling better?
Oh yes, thank you.
Good.
Close to, I would say, 80% or 75 to 80% better. Thank you for asking. Yeah.
Yeah.
Excuse me, our weather is such, no matter sometimes, you know, how hard we try to.
be unaffected with it, but sometimes, you know, it's really hot outside and when we get in, so in our car, in our office, at our home, we live in air conditioning, but the moment, if you have to step out, even at the parking lot sometimes,
Yeah.
So the body sometimes does not adapt that change that quick. And or when you're coming from your car, even, you know, walking from your parking lot to maybe your house, or maybe you're wandering in a bazaar market, you come home, you immediately, you know, feel thirst.
Mhm.
For water, you have a glass of water, and you feel like having chilled water at that point of time, and you get caught.
With weather, so this is exactly what happened, and yeah, thank you. Hi, Evan. Thank you for joining.
No.
Hey, Brandy. Hey, no worries. Are we Brandy?
Hello.
Hey, good, how are you?
Doing very well, thank you. How's the weather? Is it cold?
Just.
Chilly here, but we are in tornado warnings, flash flood warnings, hail warnings, hail the size of tennis balls in some areas, but we've been good here in our house so far. Nothing too crazy happening.
Wow.
Stay safe, Brandy, that's what I can say. And I know all these warnings, you know, it.
Play.
Mm.
You don't feel that good, but you need to stay safe. So I wish everything goes well.
Yep.
No, thank you.
Okay, welcome. Gagan, over to you, my friend.
Yeah, absolutely. Thank you. Before we start, so Brandy, are we anticipating anyone else to join this call?
Just me today.
Okay, sure.
So, thank you, welcome again.
So, we'll miss Amber.
You can just say hi from my from our side to Amber.
Oh, I'll ping her now.
Yeah.
Well, thank you for your response. You know, that, you know, I got to know, you know, I asked Show and Phoebe, how can I get a chat, you know, up to team members, you know, over Zoom, so they guided me. I mean, I can, you know, add your email address and all that, so...
Thank you for receiving, you know, my message and receiving a response in return.
All right, so welcome to this call, Winston. I appreciate that, Randy, for finding another schedule for this meeting. Unfortunately, it could not happen on Monday because of my health reasons.
I'm sharing my screen. Let me know once it's visible to you in a few seconds.
And Amber says hi.
Okay.
Yeah.
On my side, as well.
The.
Okay.
Alright, you can see it.
Thank you.
Excuse me for my dry cough. Okay, so this week...
Yeah.
As we discussed previously, so this is going to be bi-weekly from now. And this is from May 18th to May 29th.
Moving on to agenda items, these will remain the same as of now. We have highlights, performance analysis, ITBD, service offerings, AI by design, our initiative, holiday schedule, way forward, recap.
Not much, but some of the highlights, positive ones, of course. So they both, you know, exceeded their billable utilization targets for these two weeks, last two weeks also. And she improved on this ticket resolve rate by 11%, which we'll be discussing.
in the following slides. But I would like to hear from you. I know you may not be working directly with them in most of the tickets, but any feedback, any observations from your end?
Nothing from my end. Everything's still going smoothly. I see them working with the team, messaging, helping each other out. So their communication has just been really great.
Great to hear from you. Thank you. In sensible situation, they are proactive in raising hands. You know, this is exactly what I observed. But when I do board review, not on a daily basis, but I know they are mature enough and they handle the situation very well and the tickets.
So I always ask them, because my main motto is to bring down...
Or raise their.
Productivity target for ticket resolve rate. So, currently, you know, in previous few weeks, you know, that was low, so, so I always ask them, apart from the tickets, wherein user is not responding, or maybe you have some onboarding use onboarding a user.
Onboarding a machine, and that is, that is obviously may take time, you know, 1 1/2 to maybe 2 hours, and depending upon the number of items you have to perform on a ticket on number of applications you need to install. That sounds understandable, so apart from that.
within you are specifically working on putting your efforts, all the endeavors or research that is happening, and that is taking time. So I need to understand that. So I prepared some notes, and in most of the scenarios, those were genuine.
The.
They said, in one of the scenarios where Phoebe was discussing a few days back, there was a user whose machine was really, really slow. She wanted Outlook to be installed. No, there was some Outlook issue. You know, she was not able to send receive emails.
Hmm.
So I was asking Phoebe, was that, I mean, how did you identify that it was, whether there was an OST or PST issue, what was the mailbox size? How did you identify, so that I mean, their brain juices can flow, you know, answering me, that how did you identify that it was,
Yeah.
you know, not an OST or PST issue, file issue, mailbox size issue. It was definitely the application issue. So she was able to answer that. And she said, yeah, it took time because her machine overall was very, very slow. So because of which, later on she had to involve.
Amber on that ticket. And ultimately, we were able to uninstall and reinstall the application, and it did work.
Yeah.
So yeah, but that why we discussed because that ticket, you know, had taken a good more than 3 1/2 hours.
Mhm.
So, moving on to your performance analysis.
And yeah, so some of the numbers you'll see, there's nothing more than 100%, but, but so why I'm mentioning 104, 102 as well, so these are, you know, shares numbers, and so he said these are the actual numbers, so sometimes...
you know, even if I'm, you know, I'm putting the actual billable time on ticket when working with users. At the same time, if we have some internal tasks, so where whatever my time entries are required, what if I'm attending a meeting, if that is required, so.
I'm putting that time actually, and if and that day he said my shift also got extended by a few minutes. I mean, not anyone's fault, so maybe his call got stretched because of why you may see his 104 and 102 the actual time. Otherwise, I could.
you know, equilate, you know, by detecting his non-available time to make it complete 100%. So in last two weeks, Phoebe from 18 to 22, she, her total utilization stood 95%. Blue part is the billable part and Amber.
The color amber is 16% and PB's from May 25th to 29th, 79 again, and 19% non-billable makes it 98% total. And shares 18 to 22, 93.
What?
And then in the following year, 87% and non-bill will remain 11% and 15%.
Any comments from you?
Nope, nothing on this.
Thank you. And Kevin, feel free to chime in when you have any insights or feedback. Thank you.
Moving on to take a resolve date. Yeah, this is the area where I'm working with them on this piece.
Phoebe needs some improvement, I think, just because some tickets take longer than usual, which is why our ticket result numbers, you know, did not improve. However, which is why I do a board review so that I understand if she is experiencing any challenge and on anything maybe resulting.
Evan.
particular issue or with particular technology, maybe, or she needs a skill set to be improved. So this is my end goal, ultimate goal. And Shiv did pretty well in this period. So you can see in the previous period from
Mhm.
May 11th to 15, he was at 63.64%, although he didn't meet his target, but this week, in the last two weeks, he test 72 and then in the following week from May 25th to 29th, he test 77%.
So that was impressive. I hope and I really wish for them to achieve 80% number very soon so that going forward, they do not remain lower to this mark.
So, Phoebe's take a result which stood 56.75% total in the last two weeks, and she's 74.53% aggregate for the last two weeks. And total number of tickets, if you talk about she does 90 tickets more than ship.
Ohh.
90 tickets and was able to resolve 52.
that we discussed, I mean, what didn't work right. So she touched 61 because he was out, I mean, the both were out on 25th and that was a holiday. She was unwell on 26th. He had sick leave. He was out sick. So
Mhm.
He worked three days in the last week, so which is why his number is 61. Otherwise, we could anticipate 20 more tickets in here, at least 80 to 85 tickets, you know, he could have attempted, of which I'm sure.
Yeah.
I want him to close at least 80%.
Yeah, so I already discussed which are major cold drivers which are affecting their to resolve it. So yeah, that is it from my end. However, again, Amber is not here. So I wanted to ask her if there's any kind of feedback or anything, any, because these are my observation, which I'm.
Because...
I do not see all the ticket that you're getting every day from start of the day till end of the day. And their ship timing also do not match with my timings.
As per IND time, I would say they start or Eastern time, they start 3 hours late and three hours after, you know, my shift end.
Hmm.
So, which is why I mean, I get only 15 minutes time with them, and during those 15 to 20 minutes, whatever information I can gauge, so I gauge, you know, as per best of my effort that I can put in during that time period, but would love to hear from you if
I know you do not work directly with Cindy, sorry, again, with Phoebe. So Amber could probably, you know, give me better insights on this.
Definitely. And me and Amber usually talk throughout the day and see how people are doing and she gives me updates and I haven't really received anything from her for Phoebe or Shiv. So I take that as a good sign everything's going smooth. Like I said, I've seen her and Phoebe hopping on calls, Phoebe bringing things to our scrum to get help with and
They hop off. Shiv always joins and asks questions too. So yeah, all is well in the world as far as I know.
Yeah.
Thank you, Brandy. Thank you for always being so nice. You understand this, why we are asking, why we are asking because our end goal is always to improve things. You know, it should not be stagnant on the lines that we are running at the moment. So we shall always be striving to move to the next level.
be it from technological standpoint or anything, decision making skills maybe, maybe probing needs to be better. So anything, my end goal is, my ultimate goal is to just improve things or continue to add value.
Thank you.
Moving on to ITBD, so I do not think I have to spend much time on these things because someone from your team has already subscribed for this event already. So, so we'll...
Yep.
It'll be nice to see you there. Team will be glad to meet you in person over there. Thank you.
And Team GPS, this has been discussed already. So whenever you find time, you can review, you can watch this demo with our team, and they'll be glad to tell you what a homegrown tool is.
So it's a part of the same thing. Yeah, so are you currently using or incorporating AI anywhere in your environment at the moment?
Just a little bit, and we did have an ongoing conversation with Ronald and Parth about the AI by design for our phone system. That's something I wanted to escalate. I know it's been a couple weeks now, maybe 3 weeks. We were supposed to get a demo from some of the stuff we sent back, but we haven't heard from Parth or anyone else yet on progress on that.
Yeah.
We're ready to move forward. So I was hoping we could get a timeline in place because the team's itching for something and we might have to go see if there's a different product out there in the meantime if this isn't ready for us just yet.
Okay, thank you for letting us know and
If you think, if you need my intervention, you know, I can speak to my team and so that they can respond to you quickly. Thank you for sharing that.
So ITBD holiday calendar currently, yeah, so these are the remaining ones. So July is next one. So Independence Day is coming on 3rd. So I believe you have already shared with us. Your office will also be closed in July, right, on this day? Okay, thank you. And
Mhm.
Practice.
So, currently, they have not planned any PDS, otherwise, you know, we would put it here so that it'll it would be on your calendar in advance. Yeah, so things are good here. Vaid forward, nothing has changed here as well, so our emphasis is always to...
and encourage our teams so that they continue to meet their KPIs, their numbers, and whatever they think, they need an improvement.
in terms of their skill set or what anything, any support that requires. So, you know, our team should be aware and provide them with what they need.
Of course, you know, making them always, you know, feel like family, you know, sitting together and dining with them or having some outdoor activities with them. Yeah, that is our end goal.
Mm.
That is it, I believe. Let me unshare my screen. We finished, you know, quite early, so I mean, we have good time for discussion. I wanted to ask a few more things.
So, currently, we had added Amber. So, are we good with the current list of participants in our for our service calls, or do we need to alter that?
Nope, that's perfect still.
Okay, thank you. And also, just for improvement, you know, as we discussed already, so if there's anything, if you think there is any group or Zoom group channel where I need to be a part of, where you think, you know, ITBD lead, you know, should have attention on.
Yeah.
I mean, feel free to create whenever you think is required.
Just wanted to say that.
Yeah, will do.
Yeah, and...
That is it for my end, Kevin. Anything you would like to add?
From my side, first of all, Brandy, thank you so much for sharing all the inputs and the feedback from your side. I am already reaching out to the team for that AI piece, okay? Because we know that delay should have not happened. I just want to understand what went, what happened actually, and we'll try to give you the answer as soon as possible.
Okay.
Yeah.
OK, perfect. Thank you.
Okay, so that's on us and we'll get that taken care of.
Good.
In the back end, you have this owl, which is very distracting. I don't know what exactly it is.
Parth.
That.
Yeah, I thought it did. It's like a digital device. I don't know what exactly is it.
Keith.
Yeah, yeah, it's a little screen. It's about this big, like 12 by 12, and you can change different pictures on it that people create. So mine, for some reason, it just randomly has picked different pictures lately, and that one's a cat in a flower field.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Oh, okay. That's cool. That's good. It keeps on changing, right?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, it'll rotate randomly.
It's distracting, but it looks nice though. You know, don't get me wrong. OK, alright. Yeah, apart from this, I don't have anything else. Brandy, we'll get back to you with the answer soon. Rest, I'm good. Thank you. Gagan, back to you.
Perfect. Thank you.
All right, so thank you. Apart from anything else, is there anything, any other pending items at our end that we need attention on?
No other pending items. I have an interview with one person tomorrow, so we're still hoping to bring at least one person onto the team, possibly two. One is a tier 2, tier 3, and then still looking for that person to handle the procurement process. So fingers crossed, we'll have people on boarded soon.
Yeah.
Thank you very much. Yeah, same here.
All right, so thank you very much, Brandy, for joining in. It was really nice, you know, connecting with you and getting your feedback on the overall process and how you, Phoebe and Share are making progress in your environment with your team. So thank you. We would love to hear, get more feedback from you. Any insights?
We'll always be glad, you know, hearing from you, where we can add, get more value in your environment. I would just continue to say that.
Yep, and I'll ask Amber too, since she didn't get a chance to join today, if there's any other feedback she has to send it your way.
All right. Thank you very much. So thank you, Team, for connecting, and we shall meet again after two weeks with more positive updates. Thank you.
Yeah.
Yep, perfect.
Okay, thank you. Bye-bye.
Thank you, Addy. Take care. Bye.
Thank you, everyone. Yeah, bye-bye.